the hyperloop
there's a good chance you've heard the
name by now this is the hyperloop system
it can take people hundreds of miles and
minutes the hyperloop
a series of tubes that would transport
people in pods at ultra high speeds over
long distances
it's a remarkable new form of
transportation that can whisk people
from city to city
in a flash 29 minutes from new york to
dc
30 minutes from la to san francisco for
years we've been seeing these futuristic
utopian renderings of some cross between
a spaceship
and a monorail
but lately the hyperloop is becoming
much more real
it was surreal to be even sitting inside
a hyperloop and just even more
incredible to actually be like
riding down a track in something that
was nothing more than a
crazy idea six years before
companies all around the world have been
developing and testing the technology
needed to propel passengers at speeds of
over 1 000 kilometers per hour
but for many speed is only the first
step to unlocking the full
transformational effects of a new mode
of transportation
fast is what we just take for granted in
the hyperloop world
it's the network effects that really
deliver the benefit
and that opens up a completely different
scale of economic opportunity
[Music]
we've got planes trains automobiles and
boats
before getting around earth what if
there was a fifth mode
and i have a name for it named for it
which is called the hyperloop
the hyperloop hyperloop yeah in 2013
while riding high on the growing
success of tesla and spacex entrepreneur
elon musk released a white paper
outlining the basic framework of the
technology he called
hyperloop the basic idea goes a little
something like this
a tube reduces the air pressure to a
near vacuum-like environment
a hyperloop pod is then suspended in the
tube usually by magnetic levitation
the whole pod can then be propelled
forward because there's no traditional
friction sources like
air resistance or rolling friction that
would push back against the pod
the hyperloop is able to move at
incredibly high speeds and
do so fairly efficiently despite its
futuristic name however the general
concept behind hyperloop is
actually pretty old in fact new york
city's first attempt at an underground
public transit system in the 1870s was
based on a similar principle
the pneumatic transit system was
short-lived however only stretching one
block
and topping out at a rather leisurely 10
miles per hour
while elon would make some 21st century
improvements to this concept
and bestow a very 21st century name he
wouldn't end up pursuing the technology
itself
instead electing to focus his efforts on
something a little bit deeper
literally digging the requisite tunnels
via his boring company
it would take another billionaire
industrialist who dabbles in space
flight
no way not that one yeah that's the one
after richard branson would make a large
investment in the company hyperloop one
it would be renamed to virgin hyperloop
what we've always been
trying to do as a company is show that
this technology
could work that it could be made safe
and that ultimately it's something
that's happening in the next couple of
years not the next 20 years
[Music]
josh geigel is the co-founder and ceo of
virgin hyperloop
in a familiar tech startup story he's
seen the project go from a garage
to a large-scale testing facility
outside of las vegas
so we started building the first kind of
hyperloop system in 2016 we've done a
lot of
work about 500 tests that we've done on
that over the last five years and what
we realize that we need to do
is take that technology show that it can
be commercial so drive the cost down
improve the efficiency improve the
performance but the key thing is
you know is actually making it
approachable and safe for individuals
in order to do that josh along with
virgin's head of passenger experience
sara lucian
bravely volunteered to take the
inaugural ride
what her and i were realizing is like
we're the first two people sitting in a
hyperloop the only type of people that
have gone through this environment are
in space suits and there we are in just
like
normal clothes because of the system the
safety
of what we designed three two
one launch and then once we started
going
uh you felt a bit of acceleration we
accelerated a little bit harder than we
would in commercial
be like a sports car
we got to about 108 miles an hour on
that test and it's a short run it's
about 500 yards or so
and came to a stop the test lasting only
about
20 seconds and covering only a quarter
of a mile at just over 100 miles per
hour
is a long way away from a true
functioning hyperloop
but as for optics it's a crucial step
for the future of funding
the number one question we got from
investors or from project proponents or
just people in general was like
is a hyperloop safe and what better way
to show something is safe
than by actually getting people on it
but convincing investors and governments
that would likely be fronting some of
the construction costs for an unproven
technology
is no easy task first and foremost
is the question of safety most people
don't know how an airplane works
but yet they get on an airplane they get
on an airplane because
you know it's faster than driving and
most importantly they've probably gotten
off of one before they've seen someone
get off of one before
and so what we set out to do was
actually show that hyperloop could be
safe with two normal people not
astronauts not adrenaline junkies or
test pilots or anything like that
to normal people getting on a hyperloop
and then most importantly those two
people getting off
but beyond safety concerns constructing
hyperloops will undoubtedly require a
significant capital investment to the
estimated tune of around 60 million us
dollars per kilometer of track
so a track from san francisco to los
angeles for example
is likely to come with a price tag over
10 billion dollars
and before large governments are willing
to come in and front those costs
investors who are funding hyperloop
development must accept it as a
long-term mixture of
technology and infrastructure investing
investors that are used to
short returns because you're developing
apps or something to that effect you
know those aren't the investors that
really get
excited about hyperloop what you start
to see is the people that
are looking at platform technologies
right so this idea that
because the smartphone existed uber
could exist
right so who are like the vanderbilts of
this century and that's the part where
you're going to get a lot more no's than
yeses
but those people that have the ability
that the fortitude to stick it out to
see the game-changing platform here
those are the people that we're looking
for and since we've done that passenger
test
there has been a lot of interest that's
really oh this is a lot sooner than i
thought
envisioning the ripple effects of what
hyperloop could achieve though is
fairly challenging at this stage of
development it's fast yes
but for point-to-point travel
traditional maglev trains can move
pretty fast as well
and outside of china south korea and
japan even those haven't seen much
adoption elsewhere due to the high costs
and questionable profitability the
shanghai line in china for example
loses around 100 million dollars every
year
hyperloop companies however believe they
can offer something different than
traditional railway lines
my name is alan james and as far as i
know
i'm the only guy on the planet who's
written a government level business case
for 300 kmh conventional high-speed rail
500 kmh maglev and 1000 kmh hyperloop
it's fundamentally about moving people
from
where they are to where they want to go
when they want to make those journeys
and doing it in much smaller numbers so
pod designs for hyperloop range from
12 to 28 seats typically
why are they small it's because small
enables the network to operate flexibly
and a great example of that is the
east-west strategic route across the
north of england
from liverpool to manchester to leeds
so to get from liverpool via manchester
to leeds
by train is just short of two hours
today it'll probably take you two hours
driving as well in average traffic
conditions
net result is those three city regions
remain three separate entities liverpool
manchester leeds there's very little
commuting traffic
between those urban areas
hyperloop absolutely changes that
from the ground up liverpool to
manchester
is a five or six minute journey
manchester to leeds
is also a five or six minute journey
what that effectively does
is create a single super city economy
in this vision the hyperloop acts a
little more like a highway
where pods have fixed destinations and
don't need to stop along the way
meaning you can travel on a hyperloop
network from say liverpool to leeds
while the pod behind you travels from
liverpool to manchester
and if that metro hyperloop network is
connected to other networks from the
same
location you could travel from liverpool
to paris or
liverpool to amsterdam all without
making a single stop
for passengers for business
for leisure that is utterly
transformational
for high value freight and logistics
it's equally transformational
but critically if you do
a hyperloop network at scale you begin
to deliver
massively significant carbon savings too
a multi-regional hyperloop network could
become a replacement for both
short-haul passenger and cargo flights
and traditional ground transportation
both of which are significant carbon
producers
one hyperloop connected distribution hub
perhaps at an airport that is
predominantly used for international air
freight
replacing maybe 10 12 15
distributed road hubs it takes
a lot of polluting and inefficient
truck haulage off the roads that itself
means roads gain extra capacity
hyperloops will still need to use
electricity to both move pods and
maintain the near vacuum environment in
the tube
proponents of the technology believe
that this can be done by using renewable
sources
including a combination of solar panels
and battery technology
that could be used along the hyperloop
itself
but even with all multipliers of time
and carbon emission savings that a
hyperloop network may provide
the investment capital required to
actually build such a network
becomes even more economically and
politically daunting
committing doesn't mean spending
billions on day one
committing means how do we phase it
[Music]
one company in the netherlands is
working to develop that technology and
perhaps more importantly
the international coalition needed to
make the hyperloop network a reality
so we are here in europe's first
full-scale hybrid test facility
where we can already prove every
conceptual technology of the hyperloop
this is tim howder a co-founder and ceo
of
heart hyperloop headquartered in the
city of delft
and while this testing tube might not
seem as large as others
inside is a key technology to create the
on and off-ramp type infrastructure
of a hyperloop network that is a lane
switch
that's something we can already test
here you can actually see it here
that the track is diverging from one
track
into two that makes it possible to
eventually split up the
icloud track in two sections and in that
sense you can create a complete high
blood network
that in the end will make it possible to
travel for example over
over a whole continent and take europe
for example with the same ease as you
can now travel with a metro in a city
the nice thing about this magnetic
levitation system that we have developed
is that there's absolutely zero moving
components
in the track so for example if you have
to do a lane switch
all you do is that the tube basically
splits up
and statically the tracks also split up
and whenever the vehicle enters a switch
it either pulls itself to the right with
its magnets
or pulls itself to the left with its
magnets
lane switching on traditional rail
requires the physical movement of the
rail
even modern magnetic levitation tracks
use lane switching techniques in order
to transfer trains from one track to
another
and this is a very crucial element
because this
is the thing that limits the capacity
and in the end the usefulness of the
real network
because the moment that a track is
switching
that means that at that moment you are
creating an unsafe environment
for the trains behind it so you need a
lot of space between trains
in a hyperloop because you have no
moving components in the track all the
vehicles can be
much closer to each other you can
achieve a very high frequency and
basically have
vehicles moving and merging in and out
of the network very much like a highway
for now though hart's physical testing
has been limited by the size of their
tube
because the test track is only 30 meters
long they haven't tested this lane
switch
at speeds greater than 20 kilometers per
hour however the company is working to
build a new test site
where it plans to increase that testing
speed to 300 kilometers per hour
we're now in a phase where we have
proven most of the most important
technologies
in the test facilities that we already
have and we have also
demonstrated the viability and the
feasibility of a network
if you look at all the top systems that
it consists of
most of those are proven systems already
demonstrated in lab conditions
so we don't really believe that the
technology itself
is going to be the biggest challenge
because for all hyperloop companies out
there
actually building a hyperloop system
requires more than just a good product
we're talking about the safety aspects
we're talking about integration into the
environment we're talking about the
social aspects
do people feel comfortable traveling in
such a system
so it's about all these different
aspects and the complexity is really
getting all the different stakeholders
that are relevant
and that the needs to contribute to
bring this to market
to get them all following the same
roadmap
in order to help build this coalition of
private and public interest
in hyperloop development heart in 2018
partnered with other hyperloop companies
from europe and canada
the goal was to define establish and
standardize the framework
to regulate hyperloop systems right now
we are working with
all the hyperloop developers together in
setting up the first let's say a
structure
for the for starting the standards
drafting
one of the most important goals for
heart is interoperability
which is essentially making sure the
different systems can communicate with
each other
interoperability is so important because
what we
want to achieve is actually have this
seamless travel experience
so you don't want to end up for example
going from madrid to paris and then
switching because you need to use a
different technology to
get for example to amsterdam the idea
being that as companies around europe
create the first commercial hyperloop
tracks between individual cities
one day those can all be connected to a
larger network
everyone that believes that hyperloop is
a future transport system
also realizes that there is a need to
have this network because that's where a
hyperloop thrives
hyperloop is such a huge project it's
definitely not something that that you
can do in your own or as a single
company
so you need to do it with a lot of other
companies you need to have the
governments
i think in that sense the biggest
challenge that we've encountered is to
really get
all the required parties together to
take the steps in development and in
commercial
implementation
[Music]
heart's next plan is to build the
european hyperloop center
an open testing facility which will
include a 2.6 kilometer test track
and the company hopes to test travel
speeds there at up to 700 kilometers per
hour
virgin hyperloop is also racing to
construct the first commercial hyperloop
route
with projects in various states of
development in india
saudi arabia and the united states
recently the company announced plans to
build a hyperloop certification center
in west virginia
which will include a six mile long test
track
proving the technology here will be
crucial if hyperloop networks can find a
home
among infrastructure investments that
the biden administration hopes to make
the idea that there's multiple hyperloop
companies i think is a redeeming aspect
in the business
people really want to see something
happen so having
multiple people move forward is is good
for that
i was struck when
josh and zara rode the pod
two or three of the major outlets used
the phrase we now have a new mode of
transport
and although all of that technology had
existed
before those two human beings rode it
yeah
it was the moment at which those two
human beings
traveled that short distance down the
tube that in popular imagination
hyperloop became a mode of transport the
metaphor i use with my team is that you
know the wright brothers were first but
none of us fly on wright brothers
airlines anymore
if you don't continue to innovate you're
not going to be around and so we'll
continue to be
at the forefront of building our blue
back in 2013 elon had an idea
i think the difference now in 2021 is
some
brilliant engineers have spent real time
grinding out the details and i
thoroughly expect the next
three to five years to be decisive
you